yeah what because like obviously you
just brought up Swifty I wasn't gonna
bring him up but you brought him up so
[ __ ] it um
you know I know you guys have not seen
eye to eye yeah
um online you know he's a lot younger on
everything we don't see I don't know
he's obviously a lot he's a lot younger
than you yeah you know what I mean he's
probably
uh in a place in his life that when you
were in in his shoes probably when you
were younger you were probably you
probably didn't have the knowledge or
the wisdom that you currently have
have you have you considered like
reaching out to him on some positive
[ __ ] well I'm strategic with everything
that I do right because I know because I
know you guys have had words for each
other I know the important speech behind
my moves you feel what I'm saying so um
to me right now my silence is golden you
feel what I'm saying it's like
actually you at home right you have kids
right of course you ain't gonna argue
with your kids right right there it is
there yeah you know what I'm saying it's
that simple I have to carry myself like
a man and he has to carry himself like a
young man no I'm doing my part now does
he live up to his own expectations we're
gonna see yeah you know what I'm saying
ain't no need to even run our mouths no
more like and and it's exactly like what
you said it's just the age difference
though you see what I'm saying I realize
that you know what I mean that's another
reason why I'm not like persistently
going after certain topics and certain
people because at my age dog I have to
carry myself like I have the knowledge
the wisdom the importance and the
receipts to back up the way that I move
without having to talk yeah I don't
really got to run my mouth like just my
presence says it by itself you know what
I'm saying